gilles manceron historien spécialiste du
colonialisme français bonsoir gillham en
serons merci d'être avec nous alors le
débat on le connaît sur l'histoire de la
france et de l'algérie existe depuis
maintenant des dizaines d'années
pourquoi un rapport maintenant il y a
probablement un phénomène qui est due au
renouvellement des générations
au fait que les plus anciens qui ont été
des acteurs ou des témoins des faits
c'est à dire de la guerre d'indépendance
algérienne essentiellement parviennent à
un âge de la vie où on se tourne un peu
vers le passé vers son propre passé et
il y a probablement et ça je pense que
le président macron l'a perçue à travers
un certain nombre de ces déclarations en
tout cas qui n'ont pas toujours été
suivies d'effet enfin qu'il a formulées
il a compris que c'était un enjeu
mémoriel historique important pour la
france comme le fait de regarder avec
lucidité notre passé dans d'autres pages
de notre histoire je pense à
l'occupation de la france pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale où là il ya eu
un moment dans les années 70 80 90 où
cette question a émergé et le président
chirac suivi par d'autres présidents
ensuite ont tranché sur ce passé
douloureux de la france dans la seconde
guerre mondiale et donc là à propos de
la guerre d'algérie où il ya eu un
phénomène différent un phénomène lié à
la colonisation européenne
eh bien il ya aussi un moment je pense
qu'il ya un moment et le président du
mcs on l'a peut-être compris faut-il
encore qu'il parvienne à traduire en
actes ses promesses
alors l'objectif d' emmanuel macron et
de réconcilier les deux nations sur
l'histoire de là
la colonisation ce devoir de mémoire
précisément c'est ce qu'il manquait
selon vous dans les relations avec les
deux pays et pour apaiser les choses
eh bien oui il n'ya pas eu véritablement
de travail de mémoire de clarification
par rapport à ce passé de violence et de
conquête qui a été la colonisation
malgré quelques gestes et quelques
déclarations fait par les prédécesseurs
d'emmanuel macron je pense par exemple
aux gestes faits par les ambassadeurs en
algérie autour de ce massacre de 8 mai
je pense aussi à d'autres déclarations
de françois hollande au moment de la
commémoration du cinquantenaire du 17
octobre 1961
et puis il y a eu la restitution des
crânes qui avaient été conservés dans
des musées français de manière assez
scandaleuse c'est qu'ils ont été rendues
récemment à l'algérie ils ont été
inventoriés et retrouver si je puis dire
par des universitaires des chercheurs
qui ont appelé les autorités algériennes
à faire quelque chose et à s'occuper de
la restitution de ces restes et ça a été
un moment important un moment symbolique
vis-à-vis de l'algérie
peut-être pas expliquer à sa juste
mesure aux français car il y à une
oeuvre de pédagogie à faire vis-à-vis de
l'opinion française sur cette page de
notre passé alors emmanuel macron lui
aussi avait attiré l'attention c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire même provoqué un
tollé à droite on s'en souvient en 2017
lors de la campagne il
affirmé que la colonisation était un
crime contre l'humanité ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à retrouver ce genre d'idées
dans ce rapport
eh bien je pense que benjamin stora à
qui le président macron a demandé de
rendre un rapport sur ce sujet le
exprimera son point de vue son point de
vue dont on ne peut pas préjuger il est
parrain encore public mais enfin un
certain nombre de des historiens et
personnalités ont été rencontrés par lui
et je pense qu'il ira dans le sens d'une
reconnaissance de ce que la colonisation
avait deux contraires aux principes
élémentaires des droits de l'homme et du
respect des peuples et de leurs droits à
l'indépendance
reste que benjamin stora mettra aussi
l'accent sur les mais les multiples
mémoires blessées
issu de se passer c'est probable car il
a été attentif à d'autres groupes dans
la société française en particulier qui
ont beaucoup de frustration et parfois
de la rancoeur par rapport à cette page
de ce passé et à son issue qui elle à
l'indépendance de l'algérie
donc on verra bien ce que contient le
rapport de benjamin stora
en tout cas c'est un travail d'historien
assumer en tant que tel et non pas un
travail sous la halle à l'autorité du
président c'est pas une commande
politique enfin il ne la conçoit pas
comme ça c'est une commande qui est
adressé à un universitaire qui a publié
des dizaines d'ouvragés sur le sujet
alors on sait que ça sera ma dernière
question écrire sur cette histoire
commune la colonisation n'est pas un
exercice facile chacun des deux pays a
sa vision de l'histoire
oui et puis je je dirais que faut-il
parler des deux pays
car chacun des deux nations l'algérie
d'une part la france de l'autre est
traversée par des débats et
éventuellement
un certain nombre de désaccords d'
approche différente abdelmadjid tebboune
est un haut fonctionnaire sous la
présidence de abdelaziz bouteflika et il
a été reconduit par abdelmadjid tebboune
et il exprime un point de vue qu'il
considère comme le point de vue de
l'algérie mais en algérie même il ya des
historiens il ya des archivistes il ya
des gens qui ne sont pas forcément
exactement sur la même position que lui
et en france c'est pareil c'est à dire
que benjamin stora
c'est un historien parmi d'autres
d'autres s'exprimeront et ils
n'appellent il ne ne ne formulera pas un
point de vue qui serait le point de vue
de la france
si je puis dire les deux sociétés sont
divisés par des débats et je crois qu'il
faut le le reconnaître et en tenir
compte
merci beaucoup gilles manceron à d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
historien spécialiste du colonialisme
français merci à vous